I want to talk about your career you
play your I'm a big fan of your work you
are able to channel this intensity and a
lot of times playing kind of violent
characters darker characters do you
enjoy you gravitate towards those roles
or people just look at you and say this
guy should play the psychotic murderer
yeah that's it we're looking for a creep
who's and I don't I don't really I don't
even like violence like I don't like I
don't like that you have see stuff that
MMA stuff I hate watching that stuff and
and and since I had kids I like violence
less in movies I don't know why but I do
I found myself being like assassins and
serial killers and murderers and all
kind of okay creeps but um it's it's not
have no idea why is there a role that
you would like to play that you feel
like you're not getting offered cuz
you've been sort of put in this niche is
there role you'd really like Annie Annie
[Laughter]
you just end up being Miss Hannigan
Union here did you ever act in musicals
at all you know I did my first thing I
was when I went to high school I was
gonna be a baseballs and be a
professional baseball player I don't
know if you knew that or not that was
yeah I was very good and then but when I
was 14 I was I didn't really make the
cut and then that my high school at big
high school there are a lot of good
athletes went there and they coaxed me
over to the drama department to do a
musical that summer and can't remember
what was what it was mad woman or Shia
or something it was and I thought like I
want to do that you know and it was 19
girls and myself and like not a bad way
yes
yeah a lot of guys get into acting in
the first place right so true yeah yeah
and really the only reason they say
De Niro only reason no I couldn't sing
them I could it turned out that I was
tone-deaf
and like I can't tell what's higher you
know we wouldn't you play two notes in a
piano I don't know which ones higher so
they cut my solos that was the last
musical I did so Annie probably wouldn't
work out for me
but you can do it all spoken-word all
this as sun will come out tomorrow' just
walk around it do it really surprised me
that you said you're obviously
expressing this other side of your
personality that you're not comfortable
with violence and out of the furnace you
play a bare-knuckle boxer who's really
you're fighting to stay alive you're
fighting to earn a living to just
sustained yourself and you look in this
movie like an amazing fighter and I yeah
you know I'm looking at you're thinking
I will not fight him I was going to I
was going to fight you on this
appearance before I saw the movie and I
have chosen not to it was a wise
decision
Oh Who am I I'm gonna fight you will
fight Andy yeah Andy yeah but and it
will attack you while you're looking at
me that's how he attacks me but what
made you how did you get in such good
shape for that film I mean it's it's
that's embarrassed the sake I'm not
really in that great shape I mean I
appreciate you saying that but I it was
just just barely I feel like I got to a
point where I look like I could actually
throw some kind of a punch and hurt
somebody which isn't even really the
case I had these stuntmen who were
fighting with me and I must have hit
them a dozen times and they never
noticed so I'm not they're eating
they're eating their lunch while you're
hitting it's not you know and it's not
supposed to be it's a very kind of
realistic movie Scott Cooper wrote and
directed it he did an amazing job and
it's supposed to be a kind of gritty
realistic depiction of what these fights
are actually like he's kind of backyard
illegal fighting rings and they're not
all you know Muhammad Ali or Bourne
Identity it's all just like very sloppy
kind of messy unprofessional fighters
and that that's what I was supposed to
be and so that's what I was going for